this way both see mr. master of magic
your education is not complete until
you've seen mesto toughest way folks see
missed all the world's greatest magician
now here we we have an ordinary loaf of
homemade bread watch closely no no for
bread disappearing before our very eyes
no matter that is nothing you far excel
me at making bread disappear what are
you talking about I can't make anything
disappear Oh watch this there Madame is
the amount of bread that you cause to
disappear every week you must be crazy
there isn't that much bread in the world
there's that much less bread in the
world every week through household waste
yes ladies and gentlemen it is
horrifying fact that waste sheer nealis
unforgivable waste a cost each week for
more than 2 million loaves of bread
bread that is ammunition as vital as
bullets in this war such waste must stop
why I never thought of it that way
friend is we're bringing you this brief
presentation of so-called magic in order
to make clear to all of us a matter of
importance impossible to exaggerate my
little tricks are amusing we hopen in
their place on the stage quite an order
but our purpose is to emphasize the fact
that the stage is the only place where
tricks will work there's no magic that
can stretch waddle over bread and it too
or make a whole side of beef out of one
small stage so we'd like to tell you
something about this problem that must
be late not by the people in this
theater in this county or in this state
but by every living human and america
let's consider our food from the plow to
the table
we could produce crops by this method
for instance we'd have no crop worries
but we can our farmers have achieved
miracles of production books they can't
do it by magic now this is a sample of
the back-breaking work that has made our
record food production possible so huge
that the supply set aside for civilians
is as large as they had before the war
in spite of vast military needs I hear a
couple of young people who helped out a
farm this summer they and thousands of
this like them helped increase our
production but farm help was and is
scarce if the farmer could do this and
this it would again be easy but this is
fantasy and fat as he gets in no crops
thank you I here as you see is it tomato
just an average sized tomato this is how
we've treated it I waste I failure to
handle food is the precious vital weapon
that it is we've shrunk our available
food supply but was wasted last year
would have fed our armed forces and I
think of that what was wasted last year
would have fed our armed forces but
that's like throwing victory into the
garbage can I hear something we all like
I no money Oh money and it's you know
it's just really only good for what it
represents so one trick we couldn't do
without is this
that the fact is what we all do every
time we take the money we've earned go
down and buy food with it at the corner
grocery you know I have a friend who
says I see this racing is a punk so is
price control I'm making plenty of dough
now what do I care about prices if it
wasn't for racing I'd be eating like a
king there's plenty of food in America
well let that last statement is correct
anyway there is plenty of food in
America plenty for everybody if we
handle it right we've got to do two
things ones rationing the others price
control come on I'll show you where
you'd be without them
is this the only state you have yeah how
much is it a dollar sixty fine I'll take
it hold on a minute here if that's the
only stick you've got I'll give two
dollars for it no wait i'll give you
three dollars for it resin up play say
that's a mighty big piece of meat why
not cut it up and give us each a share
nothing doing I'll take it all oh no you
don't you need to think you can Bluff me
I'll give five dollars poured and take
it all myself Mabel's gonna give me the
ticket I'll give you ten dollars for
I'll give you 15 what I'll double that
wiper snapper his spin trip I guess I
showed him try and Bluff me Willie yeah
but damned if I've ever seen an 85 our
state yeah sure and I are you got all
the stake all right here the fella
didn't get any but how many states could
you buy that way that's exactly what
would happen if there were no rationing
are no control of food prices well it
all boils down to friends is simply fair
play let's look at it this here's a
typical American whole being typically
American we can take it for granted that
these are nice people just such a home
at such people as your own I suppose
this happened I excuse me I want to ask
if you'd share your dinner with me
certainly my boy you can have anything
we've got Martha get the boy some dinner
i'm sorry but i'm free we can spare
anything oh that's all right I'm awful
sorry to bother you
now we know that's ridiculous there
isn't a home in America where that could
happen certainly we'd all share with any
soldier but we also must share with
fellow citizens now here's a bit of
kitchen magic that would have helped
that woman yes that's kitchen master
that phone could have made three bowls
of delicious soup there's another kind
of kitchen magic we'd like to tell you
about is still in the realm of food
saving but a little roundabout we've all
seen one of these I'm sure you know ring
the bell when a cigar show a strong you
are well looking back at this in a
minute here all kinds of foods how for
example we'll take one particular dish
another stitch it's pretty palatable but
by itself can't provide the nourishment
strength giving we need and this it's
the same thing again but the right foods
now there are plenty of them and the
right combinations and quantities can
mean an enormous lot to the health and
strength of all Americans everywhere who
are struggling to put all they can in
this war to end wars for all time well
ladies and gentlemen we hope we've been
able to highlight a few points of
America's food situation for you the
whole picture is summed up in the
sentence food fights for freedom and it
does just as surely and just as
effectively as the most dauntless
division of American soldiers it's the
weapon that's in our hands here at home
and and we can use it to vote on our
enemies just as surely as though to wear
a machine gun and it's easy to sum the
whole matter up in a few words we were
students penis number one produce help
however we can to meet production go
work on a farm raised a victory garden
and make production count by using
food-wise number two concern avoid waste
preserve fresh and perishable foods eat
the right foods use plentiful foods for
scarce preserve and avoid waste number
three share with our armed forces are
alive and with each other through ratio
cheerful raishin and forth and perhaps
most important place square place the
war first expect to have to make a
justice make them observe rationing and
price rules thanks a lot